Farner's in Germany
should be facilitated in naturalization.
According to the Federal Ministry of the interior,
a corresponding draft law is almost finished.
Quicker, simpler
naturalization targets
demon already covering.
What is it about?
A new law is planned.
What should change?
First, naturalization should be possible after 5 years
instead of 8 years.
Secondly, if integration is good,
naturalization should be possible after 3 years
instead of six.
Thirdly, it is now time
there should finally be dual citizenship in Germany.
This means that
if you desire to obtain German citizenship,
you are no longer
required to renounce your previous citizenship.
Thirdly, older people only need to prove their oral
German language skills. That means
language certificates are no longer necessary.
Well, now the question arises
will the law come or not?
And when will the law come?
The legislative initiative will soon be passed
in the first reading in the Bundesliga
and it looks good
as the majority of parties
are in favour of the change in the law.
For more information
click on the plus sign.
Follow us and we will keep you updated
on whether the new law is coming
and under what conditions you can then be naturalised.